[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
supprimer tout pour supprimer
plus rien maintenant
[Musique]
si tu veux de moi
et votre équipe
la fois
[Musique]
saveurs de
pour bbva
la vérité n'est pas moi
[Musique]
monica que l'ouest a dit que le que
anthony le nouveau
ma vie qu'ils m'ont donnée
[Musique]
virtuel
il n'y a pas de devoir
d
[Musique]
devrait
du bébé
[Musique]
le sage
en tant que china biden nous allons nous voir
eux-mêmes
de la ligne 2
a été un fan de bottes marron crème et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doit
le goût
pour quelque chose
pour danser
bas
monde
[Musique]
efe
Regardez-moi
[Musique]
vous avez reçu que la seule chose triste a divisé un
son amour
[Musique]
la boue
à la fois
une fois
c'est agréable
dire
[Musique]
Non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]